hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday December 5th 2016 what's going on
how you doing your holiday shopping is
that what you're doing oh my god what do
I get this person um there's just not
enough time
slight Ebola by the way slight a bola is
still left yeah you get you guys you're
in the same boat as me you know I
handled some of the [ __ ] I needed to
handle you know I go [ __ ] nieces and
nephews and all this [ __ ] I got to take
care of so I don't know what to do you
know I'm gonna do I'm gonna go on Bill
burr comm click on the podcast phase and
click on the amazon link and go straight
to Amazon and kick me a little don't
rape me huh oh no bill you shouldn't
have hey don't worry about it I made a
little bit of [ __ ] cash sheesh on
this one Oh
enjoy your remote-controlled Lamborghini
anyways so I know the podcast is late I
was gonna try to do it last night but
unfortunately I had to go to a memorial
service for my friend who died and was a
beautiful beautiful ceremony and also
one of the saddest things I've ever seen
with these young kids and everything and
didn't feel too funny last night but I
learned a lot man I learned a lot by
going to that service I will tell you
that because when they did the collage
of his life in the end of it
the photos and the videos and everything
like 99% of that was about him with his
wife and being a dad so it made me feel
lucky that I'm gonna become a father
definitely because I was thinking like
what if I died right now what would the
collage look like for me and it would
just be a picture of me and a bunch of
different comedy clubs making weird
faces
obviously the lovely Mia but you know
what I mean I was kind of like what me
playing drums like what the [ __ ] that I
do to keep you know not to say that you
have to have a [ __ ] kid cuz
definitely I think if you don't have a
kid at this point if you don't want to
that's a great [ __ ] thing considering
all the [ __ ] going on with the
environment
not just have another person just to
have a person but you know like with all
of these things the great thing was I
got to see a bunch of comics that I had
not seen in a while and I will be seeing
a bunch more this Tuesday night at the
Laugh Factory
I believe the event is sold out so thank
you to everybody that came down and
bought tickets I however the [ __ ] kids
do it nowadays I really appreciate it
it's gonna be the money's it's gonna be
going to his twin boys
but anyway so yes I went that was a very
very heavy emotional night so I did not
feel remotely funny because that was a
thing out typical [ __ ] psycho comic
I'm gonna go to a memorial service for a
friend of mine that I've known for
almost 25 years and then I'll come home
then I'll do my podcast after that you
know if you think some of my [ __ ] is
bleak and dark yeah I'm glad I did not
record last night so I had some [ __ ] to
do this morning I'm a little bit late
we're editing the season 2 of f is for
family and all that [ __ ] have I made you
laugh yet all I'm doing is telling you
what a now blade in my bed and I [ __ ]
blah blah blah you know fully clothed
by the way fully clothed this episode
the nc-17 thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast did not do
well in the ratings as far as the
feedback you know it was something that
we here at Monday morning podcast
Industries decided was you know maybe a
different flavor we could throw the
podcast every once in a while I could
just be wearing a robe with nothing
underneath it that Nia could then
comment on and um you know it was like
new coke that's that's all I would say
I'm kidding actually with some of the
funniest [ __ ] photo shops I don't
know if you guys saw him on Twitter this
Sharon Stone one was [ __ ] if that was
I don't know how you topped that one
that was great so anyways let's let's
talk about let's talk about the world
let's talk about hey congratulations to
everybody up there and the Dakotas that
was fighting against the pipeline
evidently they've been have at least
able to stop it for now you know good
Lord some of the [ __ ] that they were
saying those corporate
with doing man they were playing for
keeps they were saying at night time
they had drones and they were coming in
they had this pepper spray water mixture
they were spraying at the protesters
that whole thing is so [ __ ] up cuz I
was just like why can't they just go
down to Home Depot and buy some of those
[ __ ] things that makes the pipe make
a 90-degree turn go up the street a
little bit and go around the [ __ ]
evidently all the white towns the cowboy
side I guess they tried to go through
other people's towns and they were like
yeah you're not running that [ __ ]
through here so even the white people
didn't want it I don't know I guess what
I'm saying is I should have bought a
Tesla um until they do the research and
what those [ __ ] batteries do once
they finally take those out you know I
remember Michael Jordan telling me not
to throw out my batteries you know I
believe he was standing next to the
children that's so together your
sneakers there's so much you know you
can never you can never not get mud on
your shoes no matter what you do like
how the [ __ ] do you just like no matter
what you're doing I do this and I'm not
hurting anybody or the planet just the
mere fact that you're [ __ ] here you
know somebody is crying in a factory
somewhere right or the inverse if you're
the kid or the person working in the
sweatshop right you got to be doing
something you probably taking it home
with you you know coming home screaming
at your wife that's my part of the
concrete slab to sleep on right there's
something who the [ __ ] knows I don't
know maybe I'm just an arrogant [ __ ] in
a first world country I have no idea but
let's talk about Formula One racing here
everybody nico rosberg dude the level of
[ __ ] drama like ladies if you ever
wanted to get into a sport but you just
find you know the four major ones in the
u.s. boring or you're not into soccer or
whatever the [ __ ] people watch around
the world cricket you like drama you
like all of that [ __ ] I I highly suggest
watching Formula One racing this whole
Nico Rosberg Lewis Hamilton thing Nico
Rosberg right he's the easy upstart guy
as I said he finally won his first
championship after being a bridesmaid
the last couple of years this is my
first year watching it so I'm sure a lot
of this
I'll have wrong he wins his first
championship all right and then out of
[ __ ] nowhere out of the [ __ ] blue
he retired he just said that's it I'm
done and somebody tweeted that to me so
I looked it up and I saw that it was
true and the only clip I saw was him
just standing there and his wife was
talking the entire [ __ ] time so I'm
just sitting there looking going like
wait a minute
is this guy was this her decision you
know he's got a kid on the way just like
it's just so silly I mean you know I
Drive a car to you know I don't have to
put a number on it and drive around s
turns I just it's just such a male
testosterone thing you're hurting the
environment I don't know if he got inner
ear like the whole [ __ ] Yoko thing
which people always said Yoko broke up
the Beatles which I don't I don't
believe that I think John and Paul kept
bringing their work home bitching about
one another and after a while both Lynda
and Yoko were like hey why don't you
just quit I mean you're not happy right
and then they just threw that out there
and then the their ego you know like
they were called in their Bluff they
could be like what I don't know if I
could write without him right so they
just they they couldn't do that so they
just [ __ ] I don't what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about let's get back to the gets
get back to the race in here so I didn't
know if it was that version and then I
read that uh what's-his-face
that was a Kiki lot or whatever he was
trashing Nico Rosberg said he made them
look silly and stupid and all of that
and I'm just sitting there why the [ __ ]
with this guy Quinn 31 years old you
just won your first one now you're gonna
walk away you know what why would you do
that and then I was thinking maybe it's
his wife he's got a kid coming along
he just wanted he was very emotional he
had to calm down
afterwards within this the little bit of
a melancholy / depression and then
you're like [ __ ] now I got to do this
again and you got to climb back up the
mountain again I don't think it's you
know what I think it is I think that
Lewis Hamilton was the favorite son this
is just total [ __ ] guests at Mercedes
he's sick of dealing with that dynamic
you know and he wanted to get out of his
[ __ ] contract and the only way out
was to retire so he might leave for I
don't know how long you know and then
he'll come back with a different team
there's no [ __ ] way he's not coming
back 31 years old there's no [ __ ] way
he's not coming back he's gonna take a
year off get his kid up and running you
know get the kid to be able to use the
[ __ ] right mama dada throttle break
right you got it say a few [ __ ] words
and then he's gonna be right back out
there again you know I think he's gonna
be out there he's gonna race for a
different team but here's the thing
though
those Mercedes cars were so [ __ ] good
that all they had to do was just get to
the first turn whoever won the first
turn right won the goddamn race it
seemed so I'm gonna guess I'm gonna
guess he's gonna go with the Red Bull
team because that was the only the team
that seemed to [ __ ] win anything this
year as far as the [ __ ] that I watched
but uh Jesus Christ so Nico's getting
[ __ ] trashed people like what the
[ __ ]
five reasons why he would quit
Keke Rosberg calls him a [ __ ] or
something leak Niki Lauda sorry Kiki
Nicky Claude I'm like combining names
here slams Nico Rosberg for making
Mercedes look dumb dude in that last
race when Lewis Hamilton slowed down
because if Nico Rosberg came in fourth
place are worse Lewis would have won the
championship so he deliberately slowed
the [ __ ] down to let the third and
fourth place guys catch up and and then
he disobeyed a direct order from his
[ __ ] pit crew this is I'm telling
it's [ __ ] Top Gun you know you two
characters going to Top Gun right they
tell them to speed up and Louis is like
now yeah I'm good I can still win this
race let's just [ __ ] add 40 years of
stress to this [ __ ] guy maybe he'll
he'll spin out and I'll win and
Rosberg's also talked about sometimes
you know when they're out on the track
he doesn't know how far Lewis is gonna
go he's gonna push me off the track but
Ross breaks down the same [ __ ] he did
that like twice he has his [ __ ] move
where he goes into a turn it's like goes
straight for way too long and then oops
at the last second turns away and drive
some guy into the gravel oh Jesus bill
you don't know anything about this sport
do you I don't know we'll see what the
[ __ ] happens but that's my call I think
he's gonna stay home for a year with
this kid right he's gonna go out of his
[ __ ] mind as much as he's gonna love
his kid much he's gonna love his wife
the entire time that Kenny Loggins song
is gonna be going on in the background
[ __ ] substance up they do but
deputies but do ich bin ein ian burning
not right um whatever Johnny JFK said
and then the guy in the [ __ ] pump
said he said I am I'm an egg I'm a
cookie or something yeah it's gonna
drive him up the [ __ ] wall and he's
gonna have to go back out there again
and you know and then I think he's gonna
drive for the rest of his [ __ ] career
that's my guess
alright so there you go there's a whole
bunch of [ __ ] how often you hear a bunch
of Formula One talk on a [ __ ]
American podcast you know nothing I go
[ __ ] yourself hey how about that
Patriots Rams game you know that's
tremendous if anybody ever had trouble
sleeping that would have been a great
game to [ __ ] watch Jesus Christ I
actually did I actually watched the you
got to watch the game live with me on
Facebook it was something last second we
decided to try at all things comedy so
thank you for the 1,500 people or so
that tuned in and watched me watch the
game I'm sure they'll put together some
sort of clips from that so if you guys
liked it enough if it gets enough hits I
might start doing that I want to do it
for boring [ __ ] games cuz if the game
matters you're not gonna want to listen
to me talking but Patriots versus Rams
that's a good one right and all I do
I just do the first half so anyways I
might do it with Jo Bartnik or somebody
like that maybe with Paul virzi at some
point we'll figure it out so anyway so I
have to go to this memorial service last
night I was so proud of my friend that
you know I could really see what a great
husband and father he was so I already
knew the suit that I was gonna wear
because you when you get to my age you
know it's [ __ ] sucks man you start
losing people and you have your funeral
suit you know for a lot of people it was
I'm going to a wedding suit and then
that because you get older that becomes
I'm going to a funeral [ __ ] sucks so
remember last year I got into the best
shape of my [ __ ] life and I went to
put on the suit that I [ __ ] bought
during that time Jesus Christ I could
barely get the pants done and I couldn't
wear a tie to the event because I
couldn't get the shirt closed and all I
did I put on like 15 [ __ ] pounds it's
like how skinny was I and I was just
sitting there screaming at myself in the
mirror my mother my my mother always
told me well you know she was always
like [ __ ] I don't
she was always honest about not being
fat [ __ ] kids which is hilarious to me
cuz he wants a fat [ __ ] for a kid right
so I'm sitting there screaming at myself
in the mirror right and my wife is just
sitting there [ __ ] laughing her ass
off at me now we'll go look at you look
yeah [ __ ] disgust me just just
completely trashing myself because
that's how I get myself back into shape
so I remember I mentioned last podcasts
that I was gonna do a half-hour cardio
every [ __ ] day this month cuz I'm not
putting on the pigs in a blanket
[ __ ] apple strudel what's a good
Christmas goose what do you have what do
you what do people have Chinese food to
Jewish people right what's this [ __ ]
that everybody [ __ ] eats this month
makes you a fat [ __ ] all of this stuff
the pies the cookies the Christmas party
the booze all of that [ __ ] you end up
putting on all this [ __ ] weight then
what happens everybody joins a [ __ ]
gym everybody joins the gym in January
right and it's just [ __ ]
mobbed right and I got to do is just
hang in there to about the second week
of February everybody just starts
dropping off like the Bataan Death March
or some [ __ ] right such a [ __ ] up
reference but I've been watching a lot
of World War two [ __ ] I probably said it
rough they said Bataan like what you
twirl the Bataan Death March it was a
bunch of high school bands that had to
walk to the prom that none of them have
dates to you know what I don't but it's
funny isn't it isn't it anyways so you
know what's great why don't you beat the
[ __ ] new person to the gym rush why
don't you do yourself a favor and not go
into the new year fifteen twenty thirty
forty fifty pounds overweight let's say
you knock that dumb bird number what's
that first number huh unless you're in
triple digits I you know I don't want to
[ __ ] give you too much but if you got
a double-digit figure you're trying to
lose let's say you twenty pounds
overweight why don't you try to get that
to down to a one you know get that 18
down to a [ __ ] nine get that 20 down
to what ten just knock it down run some
[ __ ] miles off you [ __ ] odometer
right come on admit it
good nobody's looking nobody's looking a
cubicle reach down reach down grab grab
a handful hi look at you huh that's so
that's what you're gonna do you're gonna
add to that Jesus Christ come on say it
with me
I'm a fat [ __ ] right just say one two
three
I'm a fat [ __ ] all right then the first
thing you got to do is is is admitting
it to yourself which you've lost control
over so many those [ __ ] Christmas
cookies but let's be honest they don't
really taste that good
a lot of them are a bad shortbread with
some shitty frosting and some sprinkles
on it right you don't need that [ __ ]
right half hour half hour every day make
a goddamn playlist you know what's funny
is I actually because I'm so dreading
doing cardio rather than listening to
some testosterone aggressive [ __ ] like I
actually was listening to like Paul
címon like my cardio thing starts off
with something so right by Paul Simon
which were you really listen to that
song I should look up the [ __ ] on my
internet doesn't work down here the
[ __ ] lyrics are really annoying he's
like when something goes wrong I'm the
first to admit it I'm the first to admit
it but the last one to know right so
he's already said like you know I ain't
there's something wrong like I'm the
first one to a minute I just never know
what that is I don't know if it yeah
[ __ ] you Paul Simon you can't I hate
when people do that
you know what I mean because they know
they they [ __ ] say that they're an
[ __ ] and then they take no
responsibility for it because hey me and
I said I just don't like it's hard for
me it's just like hard for me to tell
when I'm being a total selfish douche
why Paul you know that okay if you can
do a [ __ ] sound check okay and you
can hear that the horns are too far down
in the mix you can't tell me that you
can't be in a car with somebody else and
not hear that you're being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know and then the rest of it
when something goes right oh it's like
you lose me it's apt to confuse me like
he's just like oh oh oh let's all stop
and help Paul Simon you know that's why
it married that Edie Burke LM telling
you you don't I mean no [ __ ] broad
his age was gonna put up with his
horseshit
he had again he'd find some young chick
that was still [ __ ] wide I you know
slightly confused what
what we are right she'd know what the
[ __ ] she know know which way was up
all right goddamn oversized sweater
[ __ ] walking around he [ __ ] shows
up again I mean if something goes wrong
I'm the first to admit it but yeah I
never seemed to know I'm like the last
guy to know I'll Paul you're a nice
person right next thing you know he's
behind I just banging away
he's [ __ ] toupee slap it off the back
of his head right that's how the whole
[ __ ] thing went down and in the
meantime he briquetting the New
Bohemians right that you know for a pop
band I mean those guys could play great
guitarist and a great [ __ ] drummer
what happened
[ __ ] Paul Simon comes up with his hat
and hand showing up you know Paul Simon
guy he got hair plugs right after I
think Elton John and Elton John got the
original one so like you know his head
was so scarred up that's why when he was
real coked up in the 80s he was wearing
like those mannequin wigs because I
don't know you know what I'm talking
about I think did was I had the grocery
store and read a few too many us
magazines and it's all how to [ __ ] that
again oh talking about working out okay
I'm not here to talk about Paul Simon
Edie's [ __ ] relationship I think
overstepped a few lines there especially
during this holiday month so I apologize
all right so I start with that then I go
into one-trick pony
then I go 50 ways to leave your lover
with Steve Gadd on drums oh by the way
he's coming to town with the [ __ ]
Eric Clapton somebody offered me a
[ __ ] ticket I forgot to get back to
him I gotta I've seen Steve Gadd live
before but I never saw Eric Clapton but
anyways it goes to that and then I go I
listen to what the [ __ ] do I listen to a
couple of pretenders songs then I get
into Aerosmith's first [ __ ] album and
then I'm done
right just like that I eased my way ease
my way you know I start off really
easy then I get to mid-range and then I
just get to our Smith's first [ __ ]
one that's what I did because what I was
doing before I was I was like regretting
like not regretting hating doing cardio
and I was starting off with like [ __ ]
iron maiden or dr. feelgood you know
what I mean like that's not like if
you're just waking up and you're getting
out of [ __ ] elliptical it's all just
like Jesus Vince Vince for [ __ ] sakes
least at least I could start with home
sweet home right no you know I just
realized we have company upstairs once I
put the headphones on it I don't you
[ __ ] realize I don't give a [ __ ]
SOB's listen to that and like Iron
Maiden you know it's just like creeps
you out like you [ __ ] getting on an
elliptical half groggy cuz I gotta go
into work and [ __ ] alright starting your
day off we want information information
information who are you the new number
two who is number one you are number six
right how about Vincent Price I'll
[ __ ] work he got in the early
eighties man he's [ __ ] crushing it huh
whoa do you owe and sea for the devil
sends the beef was rad because he know
is that I'm a short let him a lot
understanding reckon the number of the
beast forty is a human number it's
number is 666 that'll do right he was on
[ __ ] Michael Jackson's Thriller right
yeah [ __ ] crazy laugh in the end I
came Ember the funk of forty thousand
years I never really listened to Michael
Jackson like I was well as people had
let it like pretend to be sad when he
died you know right it just never spoke
to me I like to [ __ ] when he was a kid
oh baby give me one more chance
I liked right up to off the wall and
somewhere I don't know I guess I like
some I like some of uh like Billie Jean
was okay thriller I thought was stupid
you know you know he actually thriller
isn't stupid you know what it is it's
[ __ ] whenever it comes on everybody
has to start doing the Thriller dance
and they always start with the same
thing where it's the claws up in the air
on either side always always there
always somebody doing a [ __ ] Michael
Jackson impression you know you know
what's interesting about that guy as
great as he was the balls have been to
critique this man is like he was one of
those guys he had the sickest [ __ ]
dance moves and then he just stopped and
he kept with the loafers and he kept
doing the leg thing and he kept grabbing
his dick and then everybody kind of
caught up and went past him even though
he was still always the greatest dancer
of all time he was it was like he was
doing the Charleston is holding his
whole [ __ ] life back he comes the
moonwalk
right somebody can't even remotely
[ __ ] dance oh the [ __ ] balls I've
shown on this podcast let's keep going
what other [ __ ] legend can we keep
could we trash next yeah I never got
into uh I never get like when I was that
was always like Prince first Michael
Jackson like to me it was it was always
Prince it wasn't even close and I don't
know Prince is funny because his bad
songs always sound like songs that Molly
Ringwald would have danced around to in
like sixteen Candles like he's got a
couple of those we just like Jesus I
guess everybody's got those right and if
he has one of those G's feel can you
trash any more dead geniuses yeah let's
go let's start talking let's talk about
Mark Twain and [ __ ] Albert Einstein
is it me or did they both have this same
[ __ ] bomb what was it about being a
genius back then or someone who was
changing the way people were thinking
that you just you had to have
that [ __ ] that same [ __ ] do it was
Sammy the Sammy Hagar and Van Halen
[ __ ] do except it was white write
Mark Twain had it [ __ ] Albert
Einstein had it Frederick Douglass had
that with that [ __ ] itchy beard
everybody had that when when you [ __ ]
are just too goddamn smart you don't I
mean like [ __ ] I don't know well you
just got too much [ __ ] to think about
there's something about that hairdo that
just it's just the perfect thing
I bet Sammy looks back it was like why
think why did I cut my hair like that
who's you know the haircut he got was
like when he was younger when he had the
longer hair that's like the chick you
marry and then like after she has a
couple of kids and she just I just don't
want to deal with it anymore he got like
literally got that [ __ ] haircut
you know just short of are you sad that
you you know are you moving towards an
alternative lifestyle here like what is
going on with that thing that was just a
bad [ __ ] period huh they were wearing
those those peach [ __ ] Flashdance
[ __ ] overalls I don't know all right
Sammy Hagar I think Sammy Hagar would
have been better if he didn't join van
Halen oh I'm going after I'm [ __ ] I'm
talking about everybody this week I
don't know what I'm doing here I think
I'm going for [ __ ] a reality show
right now give you that song heavy metal
by Sammy Hagar I like that better and
you watch him performing with his own
[ __ ] but I'm gonna [ __ ] tweet that
I'm gonna tweet that [ __ ] video this
week you know I mean you tell me that
anything he did in Van Halen not trash
for Van Halen cuz I [ __ ] love those
guys but I'm just saying
Sammy shouldn't jumped in there he
should have kept going he was on a path
the man could not drive 55
all right tall in heavy metal right he
was [ __ ] great I don't what happened
did all of a sudden I get
[Music]
right I don't know what happened yeah my
[ __ ] voice is cracking alright I
think I've trashed enough people that
are way way way more talented than I'll
ever be so now it's time now it's time
to say goodbye to all you [ __ ]
kunti's I got I got to read a little bit
of advertising oh and there's a lot to
Oh a lot this week everybody piling on
trying to get your holiday money trying
to get that holiday money look who's
back always nosing around during the
holidays right oh oh sherry all these
things are [ __ ] delicious no matter
who you're shopping for Sherry's berries
it's the one-stop shop for everyone on
your list no matter who you shopping for
Sherry's me Aires is the one-stop shop
oh I read that twice you don't have to
battle the crowds to get the perfect
gift shop with convenience right from
your home Christmas and it's this
example only one week away now I have to
do the math Christmas is only twenty
days away man so that's uh it's don't
anything else oh I already did the day's
you [ __ ] all right what do you want
here okay it's it's three weeks in four
days away that's 25 days left to shop
rapid deliver your gifts choose a gift
from Sherry's berries incredible
collection of gifts and go ahead and
skip the crowds and the hassle all
together we're gonna [ __ ] it somebody
chocolate strawberries for Christmas
they don't get these for your wife
unless you got a nice [ __ ] backup
unless you put that on the hood of a
[ __ ] toyota cressida why I picked
that one I don't know this is the
perfect gift for someone that you have
to acknowledge that they're in your life
but you don't have time to shop for them
or spend any [ __ ] money let's get
down to brass tacks or this is a great
accoutrement for a really great gift
okay and it's [ __ ] easily easy as
hell what are sharise berries they're
freshly dipped strawberries from
sharri's berry started just $19.99
that's over 30 percent so it's a round
of [ __ ] drinks unless you're in a
[ __ ] that's over 30 percent savings
or double the berries for just $10 more
you can double up there
bucks you get twice as many berries they
still haven't told me how many [ __ ]
berries I get you just need my code to
take advantage of this deal
can I get Barry Manilow to sing in the
background for sharise Barry's right
I eat strawberries that make the whole
world sing descriptive words for berries
evidently I'm supposed to use these
words these strawberries are decadent
fresh juicy sweet I hate that word
decadent it's always used by dumb people
to describe something you know is a
decadent like [ __ ] something that's
like ornate another word I never [ __ ]
use they really use decadent to disrobe
have you tried these chocolate-covered
pretzels now are they any good any good
dope that decadent all right there you
go that's your challenge this weekend I
want you to go to a dive bar and I want
you to you I want you to describe
something as decadent to a [ __ ] barf
like with no family to go home to this
holidays and I just want to stand please
take a picture of the look in the guy's
face all right choose berries dipped in
tempting white milk and dark chocolate
goodness y'all why'd the white come
before the dark Sun top with chocolate
chips decorative swizzles and chopped
nuts any incredible unique gift that's
perfect oh and incredible unique gift
that's perfect for sharing yada yadi to
it I don't have time to read all this
[ __ ] call to action with Christmas right
around the corner there's only one way
to get the amazing 1999 Sherry's berries
deal
just visit berries BERR IES com click on
the microphone at the top of the right
hand corner and type in BRR cherries
berries has something for everyone
and every taste go to berries com click
on the microphone and type in bur order
them today I'm off to blow through the
[ __ ] on DS biondi's strawberries up your
ass but don't be on DS me on DS that's
where the chocolate factory is they rub
up against your [ __ ] balls it's like
a horse muzzle wrapped in a rabbit ear
it's the softest [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself
with goddamn me undies all right picture
a world picture a world but putting on a
new pair of underwear isn't just fresh
you're stepping into a better day think
about your balls or your clam under
where is the best is the first thing you
put on and the last thing you take off
unless you matthew mcconaughey why would
you settle for anything less than the
best feeling underwear on the planet me
undies focus so focuses solely on
producing the most comfortable underwear
you've ever experienced alright for
price the price of two [ __ ] cocktails
me undies will deliver your new pair of
favored and underwear right to your
doorstep Jesus Christ isn't on
somebody's index finger looking you
creepy spinning it around
here's your underwear big boy better day
guarantee try them on they're not the
most comfortable best feeling undies you
ever had they'll refund your money and
you get to keep the first pair for free
these ober cozy undies are sold
exclusively on the me undies website and
where you can enjoy free shipping in the
US and Canada every other country can go
[ __ ] themselves alright for a limited
time hiccups everyone in my audience
gets 20% off their first order but you
have to go to our special URL me undies
com / / alright that's my undies dot-com
/ / right now for 20% off your first
order alright of course now I'm trying
to read fast and I'm getting hiccups
alright these next two ones a short here
we go tipsy elves everyone everyone
needs an ugly Christmas sweater this
time of year if you want bragging rights
for the most talked about sweater at
your Christmas party listen up [ __ ]
tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweaters designs that are nothing like
you've seen before they're not for the
faint of heart check out all our new
2016 sweaters you won't find them
anywhere else tipsy elves sweaters are
all about fun but are serious on quality
and construction while you're shopping
for your ugly sweater check out the Ella
Holiday and collegiate attire for
yourself or as a gift like adult onesies
adult onesies I've always wanted one of
those with the trap door to take this
[ __ ] out of alright from me for men
Interactive sweaters beer pong cornhole
and Christmas suits for women holiday
leggings you [ __ ] a winking what are
they not warranted up Jesus Christ Santa
Claus is coming he's an old man you're
gonna get my heart attack sweater
dresses in pajamas right now let's just
get 20% off tipsy tipsy elves c'mon
anything on the site go to tipsy elves
calm enter my code Byrd check out for
20%
why discounts that tipsy elves calm and
called alright my code my code alright
last one and then back to the podcast
simply safe everyone
thousands of people seeking home
security get ripped off every day and
and the home security industry wants you
to believe it's your only option man
they got who woods of salesmen out there
trying to scare the [ __ ] out of you into
signing one of those long-term contracts
you don't need that [ __ ] you get stuck
writing huge checks month after month
with no way out it's a robbery by
contract and it can cost you a thousand
but there's a better way to protect your
home simply safeties home security
simply safe has no contracts none
you get award-winning 24/7 protection
name best in the industry I don't know
who they could have been somebody at the
company they didn't say who said it they
just put quotes around it security
professionals watching ready to
instantly send the police and it's just
$14.99 per month that's less than half
of what most companies charge protect
your home the smart way why do they make
peeping toms just get into security then
you kill two birds with one stone you
know what I mean they get to look in
they get that little hard on they rub it
out into their [ __ ] awful [ __ ]
security guard pants but they're also
making sure that no one comes in the
house right would that work
I don't know protect your home smart way
visit simply safer calm go to the right
go right now and get their free shipping
on your order with a free key chain
remote we're 25 bucks it only takes a
minute that's simply safe / calm simply
safe combure why don't I set it wrong
simply safe where is it bird calm all
right let's get to some of the questions
here for this week hey did you guys see
over in England there they got the
[ __ ] they got some [ __ ] that we would
even make Snowden go goddamn I didn't
even think of that
they got some stupid thing over there
where they're just gonna everybody
anything you do on your phone or on the
internet or anything like any of that
[ __ ] they can just look at it it's
[ __ ] unbelievable it's unbelievable
Pope presidential election goes by they
never talk about any of that [ __ ] why
the [ __ ] do you think that is Oh [ __ ]
Obama right he was in office when all
that Snowden [ __ ] went through the big
[ __ ] liberal
all you [ __ ] who cried when Hillary
didn't get in you see what the [ __ ]
happened when Obama was in that bunch of
baby stuff so disappointed
anyways let's let's read some [ __ ]
[ __ ] here here we go advice on the
future dear bill burr Fudd
first of all congrats on the kid new
special yada yada thank you I'm an
eighteen year old guy out of high school
and need a neat career advice I
graduated with honors good for you
straight A's Jesus and all that crap but
I currently don't attend college and I'm
working some [ __ ] job in a pasta factory
sounds like you're burned out on the
academics there he says oh he said this
is because what I really want to do is
sing parentheses classical [ __ ] take
piano lessons and be happy my dream
isn't to be famous or anything but I
love music and want to pursue it problem
is I have zero background can't sing
can't play anything literally zero
there's a great place nearby where I I
live that gives vocal and piano lessons
and all I want to do is start training
my voice and start playing but I feel
like there's no point because I have no
experience Jesus Christ do you know what
it is you're one of these people he got
straight A's you're an overachiever and
you're so goddamn smart every time you
come up with the option you know when
the the normal level of fear comes up
Smarties like you can come up with like
rather than just ten reasons not to do
it you'll come up with a thousand and
you're paralyzed right now is what's
going on you said I spent my free you're
only 18 years old dude you know nobody
has any experience so they till they
start experiencing it you're already
being way too hard on yourself he goes
all right he goes I spend my free time
listening to countless covers of the
same song watching videos on vocal
exercises and fantasizing about being a
singer one day I feel I can really do it
sometimes but other times I feel like
not even try yeah dude yeah that's okay
that first emotion where you feel like
trying to do it you need to listen to
that that second one that talks you out
of it
you need to stop listening to that voice
you need to outloud tell that voice to
shut the [ __ ] up that's what I did
I literally were talking to the you
gotta beat the [ __ ] out of that voice
that one that goes now you know yeah but
what if this happened who nobody's gonna
like me sit down I need you when I'm
thinking about doing heroin then I need
you going away yeah then I'll listen to
you but not when you're going after a
dream
you don't listen to any of that negative
[ __ ] cuz you'll talk yourself out of it
anyways I know you always preach about
following your dream when it actually
comes to doing it it's very scary of
course it is however I don't want to be
40 years old and think man what if my 99
year old aunt always tells me to do what
I want and forget about money but my
parents say that I need a real job well
who has more life experience your 99
year old on and what is she saying huh
your parents they're too close to you
you know they're worried you're gonna be
homeless and all that [ __ ] so they're
always gonna say just get a [ __ ] job
so you can have enough money to put a
roof over your head and eat a sandwich
that's that's all they're thinking of
nobody dreams of that nobody dreams
about just having a roof over their head
and eating a sandwich unless you yet I
don't know unless you live in some
[ __ ] squalor right
but even then after a while when she had
the roof over your head then you gotta
at some point be like I want to do
something right I don't know anyways
I've been in between for a year I've
been in between for a year now and need
help I don't want to get massively in
debt for something I don't really want
that is so [ __ ] smart
all these poor kids coming out of
[ __ ] college hundreds of thousands of
dollars in debt at this [ __ ] point or
at least the high ten thousandth you
know that's what you love being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know cuz then you go
to Community College doesn't cost [ __ ]
you work at Dunkin Donuts throw a couple
of coffees at people and all of a sudden
you got money for your next semester
maybe pursuing music will open doors to
majoring in music in the future I don't
know what should I do you pale [ __ ] PS
give Cleo a head scratch for me pitbulls
are awesome and he says Asian need
advice from Bill burr oh that's the next
person is that it alright yeah you know
what's [ __ ] up I was gonna sell your
Asian dude you
across the piano that's one of those
stereotypes that I guessed is racist but
it's like positive racism you don't I
mean don't take up the cello you'll be
playing for your [ __ ] major cities
Philharmonic all right this is what I
would do I would just start taking
lessons immediately I would sign up
immediately I would not listen to the
rest of this podcast hit stop walk over
to the phone call the number and get a
lesson as soon as you can go to the
lesson okay and then keep going and and
just see what that feels like
don't stop after one and be like well I
only went to one I can't even play
chubster cook this [ __ ] that voice keep
going all right just say I'm gonna stick
with this for three months all right
that's the big thing with it with with
anything you got to stick with it for
three months and really work at it
working out learning an instrument
learning a language god knows I always
end up quitting I can't even get [ __ ]
100 days together just stick with it and
see how you feel after three months if
you feel like this isn't for me you're
not gonna have that well what if what if
[ __ ] because you tried it so this
isn't you're not making a decision
that's gonna affect the rest of your
life don't look at it like that you're
just looking at the next three months
the next three months are gonna happen
do you want to after 90 days still be
sitting there go and I have no
experience I don't know what to do
working in a pasta place you want to be
in this [ __ ] pasta place and you know
how to play a couple of songs dude
you'll be [ __ ] excited man if you
actually if this is what you really want
to do you'll be at work thinking about
it can't wait to get home and play the
[ __ ] piano or try my singing some
songs or whatever and then once you get
that then that gets in your DNA and when
you have stuff to look forward to in
life all of a sudden [ __ ] that you don't
look forward to you start looking at it
like why the [ __ ] am I doing this this
sucks
you know I don't want to do this and
then that gets you out of that you start
going down a path of what the [ __ ] you
want to do then
the other side of that is then your
whole [ __ ] life is nothin but fun [ __ ]
then when you actually have to do [ __ ]
that you don't want to do like go down
to the [ __ ] DMV and find the title
for your goddamn Prius right then you
can be a big [ __ ] baby about it so
there is there there's always a price to
paint but dude that's what I would do I
would I would stop listening right now
and sign up for those lessons and go in
there and just tell you teachers say
this is something I've always wanted to
do I'm just nervous about it just
[ __ ] just say what you said to me and
they'll be like I alright well let's
let's get you on that dude you'll be
[ __ ] playing piano boom that's how
easy it is to make a change in your life
just [ __ ] pick up the phone say what
you want to do and then when it's time
you show up and you do it and then
you're doing it you know you just got to
get around all those mental blocks so I
hope you listen to me man because you're
only 18 years old so it's not like you
have 50 60 and even then I would still
tell you to do it cuz who gives a [ __ ]
whether you get anywhere with it but if
you want to do that you know you should
do it alright that's it for that okay
Asian needs advice from bill burr bill I
love your podcast you're really awesome
Asian male Chinese with squinty [ __ ]
eyes and can't drive for [ __ ] dude you
don't got a [ __ ] on yourself anyways I
need your advice I came to America I
guess I always do I'm a bald pasty [ __ ]
anyways I need your advice
I came to America a year ago and I
really love tall slim Irish German girls
with red hair Jesus Christ I just missed
I just missed being your [ __ ]
dreamboat I think they're beautiful well
I'm not tall am i blonde is beautiful
too
never seen such beauty where I'm from
holy moly the problem is I'm not like
tall and confident like white guys and I
live in Texas Jesus Christ dude this is
a [ __ ] reality show waiting to happen
I tried to ask this redhead at the gym
out and she won't take me seriously
alright time the [ __ ] out dude
hat off to you for the [ __ ] balls you
got you came in from China you've
learned the [ __ ] language
right you're in Texas you're at the gym
you're talking [ __ ] right gives a [ __ ]
you went up to the plate you didn't get
on base who gives a [ __ ] talk to another
redhead talk to a blunt talk to whatever
the [ __ ] you want to keep talking to him
so what do I need to do to date a
redhead no Jesus Christ wait because I'm
a redhead like I know like there's some
secret [ __ ] handshake
he said they want me to be their Asian
friend but I really want to marry him
bang him and have cute kids this is
driving me nuts I mean am I going
against nature is an Asian guy dating
white girls frowned upon and not
accepted in America thanks in advance
I don't really cussed that much and
don't mean to offend you but I wanted to
talk and act like you Jimmy Chou out
yeah yeah okay his is Asian guys dating
white guys found upon like everything is
frowned upon in every [ __ ] country
generally speaking people are afraid of
anything [ __ ] new who gives a [ __ ]
literally like that guy before me who
said he wanted to play piano if he told
somebody he wanted to do that you know I
think initially people be encouraging or
whatever I'll always peep there's always
gonna be people telling you not to do
[ __ ] is this what you want to do sir yes
then I would go out and doing it all
right so it sounds like to me from your
email that you've you know I don't know
it's like it's like you just got into
the majors okay it's the first week you
haven't gotten your first hit yet what
are you gonna do you're just gonna quit
baseball go back down to the minors [ __ ]
that keep I would keep talking every
time you hit on a woman you get better
at it all right and I would just I would
just continue like you're doing
everything you need to do you going to
the gym you stay in shape and you're
talking [ __ ] I mean I don't I don't I
don't see anything wrong with your game
plan other than you know it hasn't
happened for you yet and this is
something you know it's gonna take a
minute you know if you just walk up and
talk to some chick at the gym and get
laid I mean then everybody would be
[ __ ] doing it the reason why most
people don't do it is because they know
that 90
nine point nine percent of the time
you're gonna get the [ __ ] Heisman hey
easy easy this is my elliptical over
here this is your elliptical over there
right [ __ ] off right for all the women
they're going like can you just like not
hit on us at the gym can you just
[ __ ] nah cuz I just have this [ __ ]
place Hey
they make gyms for that they make the
all ladies [ __ ] chimps alright the
[ __ ] you're gonna go there working out
looking good then you're upset that the
guys coming up and hitting on you
some day ladies some days they're not
gonna want to talk to you take it from
somebody okay who the women they don't
even they don't even like you don't even
like register like I'm like I'm a [ __ ]
I'm a sir I became a sir or mister like
[ __ ] 15 years ago
and it's over alright okay
boyfriends obsessed with video games now
I know somebody's inseminating email
well it was [ __ ] think I talk about
some borderline sexual self thing
obviously that's not what I'm talking
about I'm just talking about a little
playful flirtation of someone who wants
to [ __ ] you
boyfriend's obsessed with video games
how far into this podcast am i alright
someone's gonna be a little bit short I
usually go a little over an hour but uh
that's what I'm gonna have to stop today
cuz I gotta go into [ __ ] why I gotta
go to work boyfriend's obsessed with
video games hey Buffalo Bill I love your
podcasts and I'm a huge fan my boyfriend
and I love both love to listen to your
rants about whatever [ __ ] comes to
mind I myself have a DD and can find
myself rambling about something
completely different than whatever it
was I started to ramble about anyway my
boyfriend has always been a huge fan of
video games and he can play them all day
if he could more recently he's been
obsessed with one game in particular for
the last eight plus month and has really
put a strain on our relationship
he will turn on his xbox from the second
he gets home until about four hours
before he has worked the next morning
Jesus so he pretty much spent no time
together and let's unless it's me
watching him play with his friends he
talks to his friends while he plays
online
it
which case even if I do say something to
him he either doesn't hear me or just
ignores me I've tried talking to him
about it and he refuses to change or
compromise it's even started to affect
our sex life well I imagine it would
because he has no time for sexy time we
were both still young and in our late
20s and I hate that I'm practically
begging him to turn off the game so we
can canoodle in the sheets I've been
contemplating just breaking off our
relationship of five plus years because
it's been this way for months and it has
only gotten worse I'd love to hear what
the Y's Nia has to say as well thanks
for all the good laughs and
congratulations on both of youse
on the new baby bar thank you
unfortunately Nia's not here let me see
if I can get her hold on one second okay
she's on her way down I would say first
of all you've been together for five
plus years initially my first thought
when you were doing this is what I would
do if what would get make me pay
attention is I would just start going
out with your friends and just start
wearing [ __ ] sexy outfits and [ __ ]
and he'll get the message immediately if
you walk out the door looking good and
he's sitting there [ __ ] playing video
games and stuff and he if he doesn't get
that hint then yeah you got to be
thinking like what the [ __ ] this guy's
just this guy's more interested in this
[ __ ] then that when I'm doing over here
with my [ __ ] Christmas leggings going
out to a Christmas party dressed like a
[ __ ] hot piece over yeah that's
that's what the [ __ ] I would do you've
already tried to talk to him I got to be
honest with you I understand people
becoming obsessed with video games it's
why I don't play them but to me this day
I'm a bit of a [ __ ] when it comes to
video games to me that's that's a child
activity you know I mean like what is
this person working towards what do they
have for a [ __ ] job they come home
from their job and they just play a
video game for the whole [ __ ] rest of
the day does not sound like a driven man
that's another [ __ ] red flag so
that's what I would I would just start
building a life initially I would start
building a life without him to see if he
notices
and maybe you guys can get back to where
you were or if he doesn't notice then
you already have a head start on getting
the [ __ ] away from this guy
so the lovely me is here I'm gonna hit
pause and let her read this email or Nia
what if you just want to you can just
read this while I continue to ramble
here it starts right here my boyfriend's
been a fan of the video games
yada yada yada knowledge [ __ ] so that's
that's basically that's what I would do
and as I mentioned a long time ago the
last video game that I played was grand
theft auto 3 and it literally consumed
my life I would be walking to the comedy
clubs getting on a button I would be
thinking about the game when I wasn't
even I wasn't even at home I'd be
waiting to go on stage thinking about
okay you know I'll finish this set I'll
go home and I'll use the cheats and I'll
just go on a [ __ ] rampage and all
that [ __ ] and it just kind of took over
my life so here's the lovely Nia with
her advice Oh first of all can I just
say that this problem really sucks and
it's really annoying and that you're
both in your 20s and he's like addicted
to playing video games I'm sorry but
that's a lame ass and you need to move
on seriously
five years five plus years it's been
this way for months it's only gotten
worse
yeah you said you tried to talk to him
about and he refuses to change or
compromise well it's just yeah and he
obviously his priorities for this video
game I don't know if he is there's
something else going on in your
relationship or did he have some kind of
something bad happen recently that he
doesn't want to deal with or something
and that's why he's so consumed by the
video games because I'm just trying to
think like what normal healthy happy
person does all of a sudden it doesn't
wanna bang his broad yeah and hands over
his life to a video game like I feel
like something happens and he's not able
to say like okay cuz it's sticking it in
my face like well cuz you do this you
just stop talking all the way over here
that people can
I've been at the levels alright sorry
that um yeah I would not necessarily say
let's listen it's the video games or me
but you can just say something along
those lines of like listen I feel like
I'm not a priority in your life and if
that's the case then we really need to
talk about this relationship because if
you're not into it then just let me go
so I can find somebody who was into me
it's gonna pay attention to me and not
their Xbox this is what I was saying she
should do she should just [ __ ] dress
like a [ __ ] and go out that night and
just see if he notices like just have
like [ __ ] you know the [ __ ]
thigh-highs on and all that [ __ ] if he
doesn't get it then thigh-high yeah just
dress like a [ __ ] [ __ ] hi hi there's
stockings they go up to your thighs and
then they stop and there's this glorious
little [ __ ] hint of leg you're so old
that you feel like women are coming out
and like bye hi it's like they're like
saloon mistresses like on Westworld why
cuz I came of age in the 1800s why are
you acting like you guys don't always
[ __ ] it up every [ __ ] holiday you
hoard up on your birthday you'll hoard
up on Halloween you hoard up on
Christmas that's that it's called being
sexy sexing it up sexing it up who I am
on the [ __ ] ladder that's what you
guys do it's different
titties out clam peeking out from is she
no cuz I don't I don't believe in that
passive-aggressive [ __ ] it's just like
listen mother [ __ ] are you into this or
not cuz if not then I need to move on
the thing is though honey he has made
his choice that's what I think that you
don't necessarily want to fully admit to
he's made his choice he's more
interested in the video game for
whatever reason he won't talk about it
he won't compromise he's made his choice
maybe he's not into the relationship
anymore
is that a possibility is it a
possibility that he maybe she needs to
[ __ ] it up
[Music]
she's saying she's like trying that
she's trying to like beg him to even
have sex which is ridiculous it could be
that he is just not into the
relationship anymore and he's such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass puss that he's waiting
for you to be the one to dump him
because a lot of people do that a [ __ ]
has puss no but you know some people are
they don't want to be the bad guy or
they're just immature and cowardly so
they don't want to say listen I think we
should break up because they feel guilty
because it's been five plus years so
they do [ __ ] like this
to like make you be the one to break up
with them because they're cowards
you know what I mean so it is possible
so in conclusion what do you say I'd say
dump his ass bye
there you go alright see that alright
yeah you want to listen to me read out
loud oh god I know
nosewheel larious is a [ __ ] baby
realizes that I'm not good at reading
what age do you think they're gonna be
[ __ ] turn around penile look up at me
like mommy doesn't sound like this
you'll be good at reading like
children's stories
alright I walked into that one
alright here's some adult advertising
ladies it's the holiday season and you
know what that means it's I'm the [ __ ]
kidding MVM t watches movement we get it
holiday shopping can be tough I don't
like so we get it like I'm already
bitching I'm not oh I think it's the
read is we get it holiday shopping can
be tough hostility which that's your
default emotion is hostility this is
more we yeah we understand any excuse to
trash bill I see how it works now I play
the victim just like Paul Simon but
something goes wrong I'm the first to
admit it
could the last one didn't know oh let's
work on your problems
Paulie hey Paulie what do you got going
on there that was hair plugs is that a
wig does that comb-over movement watches
all that give gift-giving anxiety can
disappear with the press of a button
these watches make the perfect purchase
for just about anyone
in your life guy or girl and remember
they started only $95.00 you you have
heard me talk about movement watches and
I am sure you got one yourself now let's
finish your holiday shop and get
movement watches for somebody on your
list this is great movement watches just
start at 95 bucks at a department store
you're looking at 4 to 500 bucks
classic designs quality construction and
styled in minimalist style minimus over
500,000 watches sold at over 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns going by going
to movement watches comm / / this watch
has a really clean design and now is the
time to step up your watch can go to
movement watches dot-com / / join the
movement
alright plow through these last two here
alright our old friends Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
affordable raises right to your [ __ ]
door kid every month so you can get a
great shape but raises aren't the only
thing you need in the bathroom what
about other shower stuff right you want
to paint your tank they got the right
colors for you it doesn't matter your
skin color side that's the run [ __ ]
copy turns out Dollar Shave Club got it
right they came out with a new line of
shower products shampoo and body wash
called the wanderer well I'm the type of
guy who likes the washes nuts the
fragrances are unlike anything on the
market is that mango yes
suck it there's subtle and actually
smell like real natural ingredients
there are a lot of body washes out there
that make you smell like a teenager what
does a teenager smell like hope this
mint in cedar wood mint and cedar wood
body wash is amazing it makes you smell
incredible mint in cedar wood that's
like it dropped ice cream in like a
[ __ ] sauna
don't you sit on those little cedar wood
things right before the naked Asian guy
comes in that american asian asian asian
you got to give it a try once you're in
the club you'll see the products work
amazingly the service is world-class
there's no long term commitments no
hidden fees and you can cancel whenever
you want and best of all they're giving
away a one-month trial of any of
[ __ ] raises for a dollar with free
shipping and after that it's just a few
bucks a month get you one day
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's dollar
slave shave club calm / / and lastly but
not leastly mint and cedarwood like
there are two different fragrances
that's right it is cedar wood Vince and
that was like peanut butter and jelly
clear one scent is mint and when sent to
cedar wood I thought was like peanut
butter and jelly or turks and caicos yes
bill didn't know that turks and caicos
was an actual place that is the worst
name ever Turks and Caicos you can
believe service or Caicos but not
service and it's the word and that you
have and in your country United States
of America and Utah like why would you
say that and Puerto Rico
alright stamps come with the holidays
almost here you don't have time to go to
the post office it will be packed with
everyone mailing holiday gifts and
packages so what do you do you use
stamps calm yet dumb [ __ ] what
stamps.com
you can avoid all the hassle manna going
to the post office during the Paulette
the busy holiday season everything you
would do at the post office you can do
right from your desk SEP expose yourself
in public by and print official US
postage using your own computer and
printer print postage for any letter or
package the instant you need it then the
mailman picks it up and I evidently I
use stamps A's I do I used to have
Stockholm to send out all my posters
trust me if I can do it you can - I'm a
[ __ ] so it's that easy right now I can
I can get you a better offer from stamps
calm then what's on the homepage sign up
in stamps calm use my last name BER to
get a full week trial plus 110 dollar
bonus software that includes the postage
and a digital scale go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type it BRR that's
stamps calm and tuber guess what folks
that's the podcast for this week's this
week's this week and I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here because I got to go to
work
gotta go edit
and it had it and it so uh that's it go
[ __ ] yourselves and I will check it on
Thursday